I think it's been really interesting to see how shocked
people are by the term
tried wife and how they seem to think it's some new way of living,
like it's some unprecedented new trend.
Have you seen these millennial and Gen Z girls?
They just wanna be at home with their kids.
They wanna have husbands and they wanna take care of their husbands.
They wanna cook and they wanna clean and they wanna wear dresses.
It's insane,
when in reality, it's literally like the oldest lifestyle in the book.
Before this, they were just called stay at home moms,
and before that, they were just called women.
But now our society has gone so far in the feminist direction
that anybody who wants to live, like,
a little bit old school and a little bit like,
how women used to live is fringe, right?
Like an extremist.
And I just think about how so many of us,
since we were little,
we were raised in this kind of boss, babe, feminist society that told us,
you can be so much more than just a mom.
You can be so much more than just a wife.
And so many of us listened, and we,
you know, tried to climb corporate ladders and we boss babe so hard. Now,
like, we're,
we're a little bit boss babed out.
And some of us wanna go a little bit more back to our roots,
to our ancestors,
to the women who came Before us. And live a little bit more,
you know, like they did call us crazy.
But we like babies.
We wanna have babies.
We wanna spend the very few years that we have of them being little
with them. We like cooking.
We like running a home.
We like supporting our husbands and having good marriages.
And, yes, we also appreciate cute dresses,
the audacity. So call them tribe wives,
call them stay at home moms,
call them whatever you want.
But just know that no matter how much you try and push the career
and the boss babe and the feminist lifestyle onto women,
there will always be women who naturally
want a more traditional lifestyle.
Just like the billions of women who came before us.